l'imperméable l'équipement de rigueur
pour cette dixième édition du trail des
sept hameaux ce dimanche 20 octobre sous
la pluie et l'humidité de la forêt les
quelques 500 trailer ont pris le départ
du 35 km autour de magny les hameaux
fait bhoutan les conditions va est
optimale on n'aura pas trop chaud mais
ça va être sympa comment vous allez
gérer justement on va partir un peu
tranquille et puis garder un petit peu
du pur à partir du 20e km pour finir
tranquille et j'ai mis le pantalons
imperméables à vestes imperméables et
puis on va prendre on va prendre son
temps et faire attention aux mets les
pieds parce que ça risque de glisser
c'est ce qu'on aime qu'on fait du 13 je
pense c'est se lever tôt et puis coulé
dans la boue quoi donc nos bonnes
conditions pour un thriller
[Musique]
le parcours je pense qu'il faut c'est
800 de dénivelé donc c'est pas non plus
énorme
il faut partir assez fort je pense
continuer assez fort et puis finir finir
un peu fort le village de magny les
hameaux le site de port royal des champs
les trailers suivent un parcours à la
lisière du parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse hélas ces
techniques on est mais si on essaie
d'utiliser au maximum les petits
sentiers d'éviter les traversées de
route au maximum donc le bitume
donc c'est voilà il ya pas mal de
singles bien cassant des bonnes
descentes des bonnes montées faut
relancer les palets pas facile le rendez
vous est pris en 2020 pour une onzième
édition du trail des cet amour